charles infirmier libéral est en
première ligne depuis plus de vingt ans
alors que le pays est paralysé par la
pandémie lui n'a pas vu son quotidien
changé à l'exception de ce masque qu'il
porte pour rassurer ses patients on
garde une distance quand même avec les
gens on met un masque systématiquement
quand on arrive chez des gens
systématiquement on se lave les mains ou
et où on met du jeune alcoolique
du matin au soir il enchaîne les soins
dans une profession où le contact humain
est primordial
la visite de l'infirmier vital pour
certains si j'avais passion pour à bavay
c'est grâce à lui que c'est grâce à lui
et son confrère que j'ai un problème
j'ai eu à prendre l'un des finales dont
une jeune story donc moi les tg a
rejoint tous les jours marchés n'avaient
pas voté et au fil des années charles a
créé des miens avec ses patients et des
visites qui apporte de la chaleur
humaine au quotidien monotone où le
temps semble presque s'être arrêté tous
les jours et me demande comment est ce
que j'ai mangé comment ça va c'est
presque de la famille quoi mais moi
c'est pareil d'ailleurs j'ai la chance
d'avoir beaucoup de grands mères et
beaucoup de grands pères et que j'aime
autant que ma famille c'est vraiment des
champions voilà certains j'ai les gens
ça fait 14 ans que je les connais que je
vais chez eux matin et soir quoi ça crée
des liens vraiment des liens quand je
dis force et voilà j'ai les clés de chez
tout le monde je vois là et c'est vrai
que c'est ce que j'aime dans mon travail
finalement un confinement qui dure pour
limiter la propagation du virus mais qui
creuse un fossé entre les familles
notamment pour les personnes âgées qui
ne peuvent plus recevoir de visite un
isolement qui a des conséquences sur le
bien-être de ses patients la solitude
celle qui vous ronge de l'intérieur qui
vous amenuise à petit feu celle là on la
voit beaucoup moins elle est beaucoup
moins visible mais je vois là depuis
deux trois jours qu'il ya vraiment une
tristesse et
vraiment quand j'ai des patients qui dit
cet après midi j'ai pleuré parce que je
suis toute seule ça me fend le coeur
vraiment ça me fend le coeur parce que
là j'ai pas vraiment de réponses à leur
apporter
alors que le pic de l'épidémie n'est pas
encore atteint le matériel arrive au
compte-goutte l'accès aux grands et aux
masques reste compliquée pour les
soignants c'est sûr qu'il ya une tension
sur les gants les jeunes alcooliques ça
se retrouve
et puis les basques effectivement ça
c'est un problème parce qu'on n'a
peut-être pas tout le mal que l'on
aimerait bien avoir depuis le début de
cette crise sanitaire le personnel
médical est totalement mobilisée mais
craint souvent de servir de vecteur à la
maladie vous enchaînez les passions est
ce que vous êtes inquiet pour vous est
ce que votre famille est inquiète
et voilà que tu te g avait effectivement
d'être malade non pas pour moi mais pour
mes passions
va être un vecteur on intérêt ce
pourquoi ils me demandent de venir c'est
pour leur apporter du bien et pas du mal
malgré un climat anxiogène charles reste
positif animé par la passion de venir en
aide aux autres
coûte que coûte mon travail c'est de
soigner les gens voilà en se protégeant
certes en les protégeant sur tout mais
c'est mon travail
voilà j'étais militaire avant j'aurais
pu donner ma vie pour
mon pays c'était mon travail aussi je
l'accepté ou alors faut pas le faire on
comptabilise près de 700000 infirmiers
sur l'ensemble de la france dont 60 % de
salariés en milieu hospitalier pandémie
ou non charles continue d'être à
l'écouté au petit soin pour ces patients